we're worn down  none more worn down than our front line  health workers  who've been going flat out for two years  but everyone's tired of having to wear  masks  having to follow public health  restrictions  families  like mine just last week that test  positive you know have to follow public  health rules have to isolate themselves  nobody wants to do that  i don't know how many conversations  parents have had to have with kids  about not going to birthday parties but  not getting to have sleepovers  this pandemic has sucked  for all canadians  but canadians know  the way to get through it  is to continue listening to science  continuing to lean on each other  continuing to be there for each other  everyone's tired of covid  but these  protests  these protests are not the way to get  through it